vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir comment faire
face au djihadisme dans le sahel que le
vaste reprogrammer la mission des
ministres nigériens et français chargé
de redessiner les contours du
partenariat militaire entre les deux
pays nous irons sur place dans cette
édition d ouverture de la frontière
entre la tunisie et l'algérie après deux
ans de fermeture due aux coville une
aubaine pour les autorités tunisiennes
qui espère accueillir d'un million
d'hybrides société
c'est un pionnier du rap en afrique
leader du groupe positive black soul au
sénégal depuis trois décennies il rappe
compose écrit et produit de la musique
heures m mais aussi un éveilleur de
consciences africaines le super nana est
avec nous dans le jt ap ce soir didier
awadi est notre invité pour un futur
nouvel album
du renfort pour l'opération barkan au
niger c'est la décision des ministres
français et nigériens objectif redessiné
les contours du partenariat militaire
entre les deux pays pour faire face ou
10 à 10 mhz dans le sel harold carr
plus de matériel et une entente plus
resserrée c'est ce qu'ont convenu les
délégations nigériennes et françaises ce
vendredi au palais présidentiel de
niamey pas plus de détails en revanche
sur le soutien renouvelé de l'opération
barca nos forces de défense et de
sécurité nigériennes
le ministre des armées français l'a
annoncé ce n'est qu'à l'automne prochain
que la forme définitive de cette
alliance qui se veut 9 sera décrite avec
plus de précision le ministre a aussi
voulu réaffirmer l'intérêt de la france
pour la question sahélienne s'il ya un
agenda sécuritaire important avec la
guerre en ukraine il n'en demeure pas
moins qu'il y a toujours un agenda
sécuritaire important en afrique et
notamment dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme et ça il faut qu on le marque
y compris devant nos opinions publiques
qui malheureusement sont parfois happé
par la seule question ukrainienne or on
le voit bien les déstabilisations du
monde sont nombreuses protéiforme et sur
différents théâtres ou continent
différentes zones géographiques donc ça
c'est un point important les plans de
coopération militaire dans la lutte dans
le sahel contre le terrorisme et son
expansion ont été compliqués par
l'attitude des nouvelles autorités
maliennes côté nigérien le partenariat
avec la france est plus que jamais
précieux mais le peuple veut qu'il y ait
un partenariat de combat un partenaire
opérationnel avec l'armée nigérienne
pour permettre justement à ce que
l'intégrité structurelle du niger puisse
être sauvegardés donc dans les espaces
que nous avons nous là cette situation
on barca nous appuiera où les allemands
plutôt de la défense nous appuierons
c'est qui va permettre comme ça a été
dit à l'assemblée nationale à l'armée
nigérienne des pouvoirs continue sa
montée en puissance devrait pouvoir
continuer à s'équiper pour qu'elle
accueille quelques arrivées agi seul les
deux pays ont annoncé vouloir lutter de
manière conjointe contre la
désinformation qui a eu lieu contre
cette alliance militaire renouvelé au
mali cette même des informations a accru
le sentiment de défiance dans une partie
de l'opinion publique malienne contre
l'armée française
une nouvelle attaque meurtrière au togo
la troisième en quelques mois au moins
trois villa située près du burkina ont
été attaqué la nuit dernière par des
groupes non identifiés
un bilan provisoire fait état de 15
morts pour l'instant le président s'est
rendu sur place des précisions avec
emmanuel sodji notre correspondante dans
la région les médias locaux évoquent au
moins une quinzaine de morts parmi les
villageois de villages ont été
particulièrement ciblés par des
djihadistes présumés la nuit dernière il
s'agit de bla manga et paimpol ces deux
localités sont situées dans le canton de
coin de jarret dans la préfecture du
pendjab une préfecture qui est située
pas loin de la frontière avec le burkina
faso alors ce qui a changé dans le mode
opératoire par rapport aux précédentes
attaques c'est que les assaillants ont
tué les civils avec une violence inouïe
ils les ont surpris dans leur sommeil et
les ont égorgés les présumés jihadistes
aurait également poser des engins
explosifs sur les pistes qui mènent vers
ces villages attaqués conséquence ce
vendredi matin le véhicule du
commissaire de police et deux de ses
éléments qui avaient quitté la ville
voisine de mandouri pour se rendre sur
les lieux des drames on se tait aussi
sur une mine artisanale il aurait été
blessé et conduit à l'hôpital de dapaong
la dégradation de la sécurité dans
l'extrême nord du togo a amené le
gouvernement togolais donc à instaurer
un état d'urgence sécuritaire dans la
région des savanes depuis la mi juin
dans ce cadre là un poste militaire
avancé a été installé dans le même
canton ont eu lieu ces attaques le
changement de mode opératoire pourrait
donc s'expliquer par la présence de ce
nouveau poste qui n'est pas loin des
villages attaqués cette nuit sans
compter tous les nouveaux chaque pointe
l'actualité au maghreb c'est la
réouverture de la frontière entre
l'algérie et la tunisie elle était
fermée depuis deux ans à cause de la
pandémie de kevin 19 une bonne nouvelle
pour les professionnels du tourisme
florent rodo avec les images
correspondantes en tunisie
des véhicules libre de passer de la
tunisie à l'algérie après un simple
contrôle de police cela faisait plus de
deux ans que l'on avait plus vu cela
depuis ce vendredi la frontière
terrestre entre les deux voisins
maghrébins est à nouveau ouverte à tous
pour l'occasion plusieurs ministres
tunisiens ont fait le déplacement dont
celui des transports
une journée importante pour lui et son
pays bien se préparer au niveau de
l'accueil au niveau de tous les services
vitaux les algériens lorsqu'ils viennent
ici et sont considérés comme des
tunisiens et il le sent d'ailleurs parce
que il s'agit de deux
pays sur lesquels s'est divisée un seul
peuple est ce pour cela que cette
journée est une journée historique la
tunisie et l'algérie compte neuf postes
frontaliers tous ont été fermées en mars
2020 pour freiner la propagation du
coffee 19 une crise sanitaire qui a
sévèrement ralenti le trafic routier
limité pendant plus de deux ans au seul
transport de marchandises les liaisons
aériennes et maritimes avait-elle repris
en juin 2021
une frontière terrestre fermée aux
touristes synonyme d'un immense manque à
gagner pour les professionnels du
secteur en tunisie car leur pays est
depuis longtemps l'une des destinations
préférées des algériens
rien que cet été pas moins d'un million
d'entre eux sont attendus sur le sol
tunisien ils étaient trois fois plus
nombreux avant la pandémie
au congo brazzaville sans surprise c'est
le parti au pouvoir qui remporte les
élections législatives de dimanche
dernier le parti congolais du travail
est au pouvoir depuis 1968 les
explications brazzaville de rosé piotte
61% de congolais ont pris part aux
élections législatives de dimanche
dernier selon les chiffres du ministère
de la décentralisation qui a publié le
résultat tard dans la nuit de jeudi le
parti au pouvoir et ses alliés
l'emportent haut la main avec plus de
100 sièges tandis que l'opposition glane
quatre sièges pour l'upa dess de pascal
tsaty mabiala et trois sièges du côté
des luttes et à chippis en attendant le
second tour vivienne un goût candidat
indépendant malheureux dans la
circonscription électorale de tié tié
dans la ville de pointe-noire donc
contester les résultats devant le juge
constitutionnel
vous avez en face de vous un homme déçue
mais déterminée à se battre pour sauver
la victoire pas ma victoire la victoire
de tous les gens qui ont voté pour moi
heureusement qu'au congo les résultats
qui sont proclamés par le ministre en
charge des élections sont des résultats
provisoires nous allons saisir la cour
constitutionnelle pour faire constater
les nombreuses irrégularités qui aux
dires qui entend tâche et lectures notre
circonscription ce vendredi le collectif
tournons la page a également dénoncé le
manque de transparence de ces scrutins
il faudrait pas maintenant qu'on
consacre dans notre pays
des pratiques qui sont contraires à la
loi puisque j'ai dit que la loi
électorale n'a pas été respectée donc le
gouvernement se doit de respecter sa
propre loi électorale la commission
nationale électorale indépendante a
quant à elle salué le bon déroulement du
scrutin et appeler les perdants h si tu
n'es pas défier l'état un second tour
sera organisé dans les prochains jours
pour départager les candidats en
ballottage
notre invité de ce soir est plus qu un
créateur c'est autant initiateurs qu un
éveilleur de conscience ou diapason de
la jeunesse sénégalaise d'abord là où il
est né ensuite africaine où ce continent
dont il se revendique le porte-voix
d'abord avec le mythique groupe de rap
positive black soul avant de se lancer
seul devenu depuis une soupe en dan
didio a dit merci d'être l'invitée du
journal de l'afrique merci de
m'accueillir alors avant de parler de
cet nouvel opus pour lequel vous êtes là
un point d'étape 30 ans de carrière
dites nous comment quel est le secret
pour durer autant dans ce métier je
pense que c'est la passion
passion pour cette star cette culture
qui allie pop à ce chantier pour pour
l'écriture passion pour le continent et
voilà passion pour l'histoire de ce
continent voilà je pense que cette
musique nous permet de participer à
l'écriture de l'histoire donc on a
décidé c'est un sacerdoce et puis on
s'est collé depuis lors la passion elle
n'a jamais bougé dans tron est la voie
la main pour notre plus grand plaisir
alors quel regard portez-vous sur cette
nouvelle génération sachant que vous
êtes aussi producteur et qu'il aura pas
beaucoup changé d'ailleurs depuis vos
débuts wydra pas beaucoup changé il ya
une nouvelle génération décomplexée qui
arrivent et qui n'a même plus les rêves
que nous avions d'amérique des rêves
d'europe et elle se construit sur le
continent elle se développe sur le
continent c'est les patrons
d'entreprises aujourd'hui ils sont
jeunes ils n'ont pas 25 ans ils savent
c'est quoi être millionnaire ils savent
négocier leurs contrats et savent
utiliser tous les codes du digital
franchement moi je suis juste énervé et
aujourd'hui c'est la musique numéro un
en afrique c'est la musique qui remplit
tous les stades d'afrique du nord au sud
de l'est à l'ouest et donc je pense que
ne pas faire attention à cette jeunesse
c'est une erreur et certains ont fait
l'erreur de ne pas les écouter et s'en
sont mordu les doigts parce que même les
changements politiques viennent quelque
part de la rue bien quelque part de ses
messagers de la russe de ses porte voix
de la rue vos sources d'inspiration
c'est l'actualité évidemment beaucoup
d'acteurs beaucoup d'actualité donc en
ce moment vous buvait du petit lait où
je n'en ai pas pour moi c'est
on les remercie tous ah oui on les
remercie vous et les chansonniers tout
le monde se régale en ce moment et alors
le rap oui évidemment et on le voit dans
votre dernier opus géométrie variable
j'aimerais qu'on en écoutant exprès et
on en a juste après
t'nb nous parce que poutine en veille
l'ukraine et tout à coup toutefois les
bons mais ça ça te fait de la peine
dubois depraz m'a d'abord tu peux pas
rester m² ce tournoi le même sang qui
coule dans les veines tout est gris ni
parce que maintenant tu vois la guerre
c'est pas les chiffres à la télé c'est
désormais des frères et tout à coup tu
bois le vrai sens du mot misère y'a pas
d'abri ya pas des chiens ya pas de père
et mère
un extrait un tout petit extrait de
géométrie variable ça va être le nouvel
opus se veut être le prochain single
donc là je suis à paris pour terminer
justement le travail sur l'album donc ça
va être le septième et géométrie
variable c'est important pour nous de
rappeler que chez moi aussi il se passe
des choses horribles et personne n'en
parle tu vas aujourd'hui puisque c'est
l'ukraine puisque c'est des gens qui
ressemble aux bien pensants donc là tout
le monde s'indigne mais quand c'est un
petit malien français un congolais quand
c'est quelqu'un qui est dans le nord
kivu voilà c est on sait ne gagne pas
plus que ça tu vois et je pense qu'on
aurait s'indigner sur tout ce qui se
passe aussi en afrique et rappeler aux
gens que nous existons et s'ils ne le
comprennent pas eh bien ils le sentiront
d'une manière ou d'une autre donc voilà
c'est ça et il ya trop d'indignation à
géométrie variable les gens ne s'indigne
pas assez par rapport à ce qui se passe
chez nous il ya des scandales qui
restait là depuis des siècles et ça
continue et à l esclavage dans certains
pays qui compte les délits de démocratie
selon que il la rage
[Musique]
le pays du nord ou pas voilà on s'en
indigne ou pas donc il ya des gens qui
ont toujours
insulté la démocratie et tout le monde
s'en fout mais au delà de l'indignation
justement en termes d'actions qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire pour changer les choses
parce qu'il se passe des choses sur ce
continent juste avant il se passe des
choses sur le sur le continent je pense
qu'aujourd'hui
les gens la rue lajeunesse a décidé de
prendre son destin en main décrire ce
sont son destin d'être responsable et
propriétaire de son avenir et donc nous
notre rôle c'est d'accompagner toute
cette jeunesse qui a décidé d'écrire son
avenir et
en tout cas dans l'album qui vient on a
décidé de passer à une autre étape
parce qu'à un moment je me suis retiré
je regardais tous les enseignants on ne
peut pas être si je reste trop
silencieux ce serait une forme de
complicité donc le prochain album qui
s'appelle quand on refuse on dit non
c'est c'est un peu notre boribana la
flûte est terminée il faut être face à
notre destin absolument on l'attend avec
impatience peut-être y aura une tournée
peut-être en afrique il y aura une
tournée en afrique est beaucoup plus
loin qu'en afrique mais l'afrique est
notre première cible pièce aujourd'hui
évidemment merci beaucoup a dit d'être
venu sur ce plateau c'est ainsi que nous
refermons ce jour n'a de l'afrique merci
à tous ceux qui l'ont suivi maintien de
cap 6 à cotonou en passant par abidjan
ou à gallo mais addis abeba parce qu'il
est partout évidemment sur le continent
africain restez avec nous car
l'actualité continue sur france 24 merci
[Musique]